provando a ragionare sul tema
dell'armonia
ci siamo resi conto che non sappiamo
nulla ma riconosciamo il suo balzo del
sangue quando un corpo insolito canta
nello stupore di un pubblico in sala
forse può essere che questo corpo che è
teso proteso in un abbraccio del mondo
questo insieme di difformità può essere
che questa l'armonia della vita quando
whitman afferma il canto è per il
cantante ea lui torna sapeva bene che il
canto quando parte nel ritorno ha
raccolto tutto l'ascolto appassionato e
quell eternità della vita è in quel
momento dell'incontro fra una voce e uno
scontro allora l'armonia è un canto
nell'eternità del tempo
[Musica]
poi la notte
[Applauso]
ora tutti
[Musica]
[Applauso]
mi aspetto
[Musica]
ti senti tutti questi
rapporti
che avanzano non sono verbale e stridere
di ferraglia calpestio di tacchi piedi
nudi a milioni la terra segnata da
questo passaggio
fa rumore come l'oceano di balene lo
senti l'aratro dei sogni fa solchi
profondi
perché gli uccelli non possano pregare
piovono petali
pedali
meta
[Musica]
ciao
si no
no
[Musica]
[Applauso]
all
[Musica]
santo santo santo santo santo tutto e
santo scrive allen ginsberg
dopo di che segue un elenco di nomi di
cose
ora forse è il tempo di aggiungere a
quell'elenco a quei nomi santo ginsberg
santa poesia sante le bocche che dicono
la poesia e riversano lapo la poesia in
altre bocche bisogna aggiungere santi
social santo facebook perché sono
antidoto alla peste di questo millennio
che è la solitudine
poi noi umani col nostro tempo
impareremo a dosare bene a utilizzare
bene perché siano occasione di incontro
di corpi e i corpi sono pieni di attese
di incontri per che fioriscano le parole
di curiosità di intelligenza perché le
parole colgano il cuore del mondo il
cuore delle cose forse l'armonia è la
pazienza del cercarsi per parlarsi vita
con vita
anche i corpi strani come il mio sono
belli credevo di essere brutto da vedere
ma se ci sono
vuol dire che devo essere guardato
anch'io ogni corpo anche se diverso è
figlio di qualcuno
anche io lo sono
nel tempo la lista di cose che non avrei
potuto fare si è allungata a dismisura
certo a sentirlo raccontare
sembro messo un po male
eppure e pur guardando mi dico
sto bene io sto bene
siamo tutti figli nati da un corpo di
donna sopravvissuti a un travaglio a un
parto e con ottime probabilità
sopravviveremo alla prossima morte
andaloni grandi d'italia e fattura
indossati in ordine tali eleganza da
acerbi corpi uomini forse così siamo
tutti siamo uomini ulisse siamo corpi
che indossiamo il mondo nati e morti di
placenta e placenta di nero in nero è
invasione la vita anche nella forma
oscura dell'assenza
nel frattempo c'è questa vita insieme
c'è questa occasione questa possibilità
di gioia insieme cosa ne vogliamo fare
lasciamo vincere chi pensa che la morte
è per sempre
o vogliamo vincere pensando che la morte
è occasione di nascita la bellezza
ferisce e spiraglio porta finestra
perché gli umani dicono ero sul sangue
azzurro il cielo sono verdi i tuoi occhi
conoscerti è stato un piacere un
naturale invito alla festa del vivere
l'armonia inizio quando una parola è un
fotone che attraversa contemporaneamente
due feritoie la tua bocca e i miei occhi
sarà un arcobaleno di pelli sarà un
mercato di sguardi e il cielo il cielo
sordi era di nuovo sarà un gesto sarà un
bacio
sarà una traccia condurre un amore e
invasione la vita bisogna imparare a
scegliere il cuore delle parole
abbiamo tutti bisogno d'amore
abbiamo tutti un benessere da
raggiungere da conquistare ma il cuore
delle parole significa che benessere è
essere bene e bisogno d'amore è uno
strumento per distinguere dei
tachicardie cardiache dal volere l'altro
veramente felice allora l'armonia è la
scelta che facciamo tra il vivere
insieme o il morire dell'altro
se è destino che si muoia
siamo il numero più che sufficiente e 6
viviamo meno siamo più grande sarà la
nostra parte di gloria ti prego non
desiderare un solo uomo di più anzi chi
non si sente l'animo di battersi
quest'oggi se ne vada a casa
gli daremo il lasciapassare e gli
metteremo nella borsa i denari per il
viaggio
nessuno di noi vorrebbe morire in
compagnia di qualcuno che temesse di
esserci compagno nella morte oggi è la
festa dei santi crispino e cristiano
colui che sopravviverà a quest oggi e
tornerà a casa si leverà sulle punte
sentendo nominare questo giorno e si
farà più alto e mostrerà a tutti le sue
cicatrici e dirà queste ferite
le ho ricevute il giorno di san crispino
da chi si dimentica
ecco che gli altri dimenticherà presto
ricorderò con grande fierezza le gesta
di questo giorno
allora i nostri nomi a lui familiari
come parole domestiche saranno neri
brindisi rammentati e rivivranno pochi
ma importanti marchi che oggi combatterà
sarà mio fratello
allora chart gentiluomini ora a letto in
patria saranno maledetti per non essere
stati qui con noi e minuti nella loro
verità sempre non nominare chi ha
combattuto con noi
quest'oggi una volta attaccate l'avrei
gli amici di netti
ancora una volta ori chiuderemo il varco
con i corpi dei nostri morti in tempo di
pace non la sa dice tanto all'uomo
quanto la moderazione
la calma e l'unità ma quando squilla
nell'ora che la tomba della guerra
allora limitate
l'azione della tigre irrigidite i
muscoli fate appello al vostro sangue
nascondete la mitezza naturale sotto il
furore dal volto feroce prestate ai
vostri sguardi un'espressione terribile
che gli occhi scrutino attraverso le
feritorie del campo come bronzei cannoni
stringete ora i tanti
diradate le narici trattenete il respiro
e tendete ogni energia all'estremo ogni
preparativa è fatto sei cuore pronta a
battersi conoscete i vostri posti ha
donato 1
siamo questo è né un teatro tutti gli
uomini saranno liberi fra mille anni a
partire da subito e dalla mia vita
questo manipolo di irriducibili questo è
né un teatro sono corpi
siamo tutti i corpi ciascuno col proprio
deficit arruolati nell'armata dell'arte
genieri del teatro con una visione
dell'umanità che non è quella di oggi
non è quella di oggi che muore sotto le
bombe che muore per inimicizie presunte
siamo la maggioranza dell'umanità
siamo monica piero danielo stefania
maria stella alpina manuela luca sofia
alessandro jessica e tanti tanti tanti
tanti altri con tutti voi compresi
[Applauso]